The most prominent conspiracy theory was
coming from a pan down insurance,
a insurance company investigation that
was ran by a guy called
who pretend to be an officer,
a code named abner that wrote the book
vengeance.
That was the basis for the Spielberg
movie,
Munich Olympic massacre.
Everything that he wrote is false.
I saw and I had numerous meetings and
conversations with him every time that
we reached a point where he was supposed
to give me the smoking gun,
one conclusive evidence that proves a
that it wasn't
that it was Iran sending the Pfl G,
I'm a organization to take revenge for
taking off the Uranian Airbus aircraft
by the U.
S Vincent's a ship by Mr and that the
CIA had a unit called Korea that was
involved in taking out a Pan Am 103 for
their reasons.
Every time that we reach that smoking
gun.
He said,
no,
it's in a safe in Europe.
I will just about.
I'm going to give it to you tomorrow.
It will take me few more hours.
I never saw any real conclusive evidence
that connects Iran to this case or this
connected Libyans and at the end of the
day,
while my Kadafi paid compensations,
so I don't know from his point of view
why I gave the person involved to a
trump,
why would he,
why would he pay con conference con?
Why would he pay any money
for something that he didn't do?
A very positive example and very
negative example to negotiating on
nuclear issues.
The very positive as Libya,
the mic and CIA got involved with the
son of Kadafi who convinced this father,
who used to be considered the most crazy
of all Middle East leaders to compromise
and to give up everything for western
support.
This is very positive and they complied
with all promises that they gave and
disassembled the whole of their nuclear
project.
The negative example with be,
of course,
North Korea that sign a sort of a deal
with President Clinton just to stall
time and have more nuclear advancement
that lead them to a bomb.
Now,
the lesson would be I think that the US
should deal or should negotiate with
Iran if the Iranians are willing to
negotiate,
the US cannot afford to refused
negotiation with what I see as the worst
security challenge the US is facing.
And this is Iran.
If Iranians are willing to negotiate,
the US should deal with them without
preconditions.
I know that general,
uh,
Senator John Mccain,
he preaches for preconditions.
I don't support this view.
I think that the US should go to the
negotiation table,
but just making sure that Iran is not
just doing it as he did to your to gain
time.
If Iran is willing to negotiate the,
uh,
stopping the enrichment of uranium
cutting relations with Iraqian Afghany,
insurgencies stopping a to Hamas
and,
uh,
stopping promoting his butler.
I,
I think that this would be great.
This would be a major solution and a
peaceful solution.
And maybe the last chance before,
before a striking Iran,
I would gloomily globally a suspect that
the Iranians will not give all this
which they deem is a very interesting,
very important interest.
And at the end of the day,
a much more harsh action would be taking
place.